think it's harder to find the truth as
you become more successful
100 but you learn to say okay I
appreciate that but now come on it's one
of the most popular illusionists he's
earned 11 Guinness World Records the
most successful commercial Magician of
all time is he's walked through the
Great Wall of China he's made the Statue
of Liberty disappear give it up for the
legendary David Copperfield
to have a career this long is is rare in
Hollywood as you know it's all based on
fear it's all based on fear
you know my mother you know didn't want
me to do this right it was a big fear to
that I would not have a job so I had to
prove to myself that maybe it's possible
is it still as joyful today as it was 20
years ago 30 years 40 years ago
[Music]